what's going on guys this is rob and my
body saw fit to give me this so i'm
currently working to try to get rid of
it you guys want to see something really
cool
check this out
that's alex ross art
that is alex ross's captain america and
that's alex ross's superman there are
actually two parts of a uh of a single
series and then
that is uh blue lantern captain america
versus red lantern bucky barnes
but i had those commissioned uh or at
least had that one commissioned by a fan
the captain america and the bucky barnes
i had that commissioned by a fan which
is just really really awesome so that's
a one of a kind it's unique you can't
find it anywhere else but uh in any
event we are bringing people on nikki
culture explains so we are doing the
press junket for the morbius film but i
want to specify ahead of time it won't
actually be me it's going to be a guy
named quran that we brought on from the
nice cast really really cool guy he's
really awesome uh but we brought him on
to cover some of the press junkets that
are going on here at geek culture
explain we're also launching more shorts
and we're looking at bringing somebody
on for shorts content and then we have
podcasts one of which is going to
absolutely blow your mind when that
podcast launches
sun sun sun it's going to blow it's
going to blow your mind it's going to be
absolutely amazing but anyway guys uh
let's get on with the press junk i just
want to make a quick little video
letting you guys know what's going on
and why you're not going to see me there
got an angel with comics explained uh
jared leto pleasure to meet you man
good to meet you too brother
so
i always wonder anytime i see well first
and foremost congratulations for morbius
uh anytime i see you whether it's films
or ig live streams or red carpet
appearances i'm always curious uh when
are you gonna drop the haircare routine
for us
oh look at that hair over there man
man you got a lock locks of love over
there yeah
genetics and florida heat would end with
all these lights i got on in this room
we were kind of we're one of those twins
you got a little bit more of a bob than
i i don't know
a little bit more of a bob um
you know you're looking good man i don't
know like i'm trying to follow higher
footsteps well i guess uh i don't know
what it is but you know
appreciate you man i'm just going to
admit it it's a wig okay it's a wig
tape it on and off
breaking news jared leto wears a wig
um so
now morbius isn't your first rodeo when
it comes to the superhero comic book
culture community
but it is the first time you are
interpreting a character that has never
been in live action before and i was
watching one of your interviews where
you were talking about sort of your
commitment to artistry and
self-expression so i was wondering is
there any
internal dialogues when you
are
working on a character who has this long
lineage of
interpretations throughout various forms
of mediums
or is there sort of more apprehension
about
interpreting a character that's
relatively a clean slate within uh
general audiences like morbius
i mean i was really excited to bring
this character to the screen the big
screen for the very first time
i mean i think that's quite an honor
it's really hard to find a character
that hasn't
been realized by someone else you know
especially in the in the marvel canon
it's uh
it's it's more and more rare
um
[Music]
less and less likely that you're gonna
have the opportunity
and and you know so i yeah i feel like
pretty special pretty pretty fascinating
and i really loved it
nice
now uh speaking of that commitment to
self-expression i feel like that is
becoming somewhat increasingly more
difficult in today's society it feels
like you know anything you kind of say
or do you we're all under this
microscope of sorts so in your
reflective moments do you ever think
about where that commitment to
self-expression kind of originated
because i do think that's that's
important uh for artists and i think
even just media personalities moving
forward
i don't know that's a very big question
you know i just hunkered down and try to
do the very best that i can i try to you
know with as much dignity and grace as i
can muster really i try to do the best
job that i can
you know i never i i always feel like i
owe it to audiences to do my best even
in if i fail
gloriously it's like you know i i took a
swing
and uh i think it's better to fail than
not to take uh to be than not to take a
great risk i'd rather take a great risk
and fail than than not risk at all
um and i i think i owe it to myself i
owe it to the filmmakers i owe it to
audiences and i'll continue to do that
yeah and you know i've like i've been
teaching myself filmmaking over the
pandemic and that's something that i've
kind of been struggling with of like
we all want to be un inhibited
artistically but we also have to adapt
to what the current climate and things
are in regards to okay maybe i need to
kind of maybe filter myself a little bit
with with what i'm saying or how i'm
saying it so i feel that's a constant
dilemma and i feel like that kind of
suits the character of morbius of
this internal dilemma of
sure but when it comes to be when it
comes to being an artist and like you
know
with your art it's you you really have
this the world and follow your
your your your dreams i mean you you you
have to
you have to be willing to upset
some people
and i think that you know when it comes
to fit you're talking about your
personal art and what you have to say
you know i i i believe in you know
thousand percent and
and your freedom to express yourself and
your
creative dreams that's a good that's a
beautiful thing
ftw we're gonna wrap this interview with
ftw uh jared leto thank you for your
time it was a pleasure meeting you
congratulations once again
thanks brother bye-bye
adria uh daniel pleasure to meet both
you guys uh and uh congratulations on
the film
thank you
so adria it's our first time talking so
i have to be transparent uh i spent a
considerable amount of time watching
youtube videos of you um specifically
ones in which you were introducing
yourself because i wanted to get the
pronunciation of your name correct so
how did i do i really appreciate it i
think you did a really really good job
thank you for now because i'm indian and
in my
i'm indian so my name is kat and that's
the indian pronunciation but i get
called karen koran and i don't want to
be a stickler about it so those are fine
but uh i also get called karen as well
and uh it's not really an endearing time
to be called karen
thank you uh and those cultural
intricacies really fascinate me that's
what i kind of wanted to lead off with
daniel and ask you um
as a foreign filmmaker is there sort of
a personal responsibility you feel to
interject and infuse
some of the the cultural sensibilities
of sweden and swedish cinema in general
yeah sure sure but you know i'm also
chilean i'm a refugee and
you know and i was brought up in west
africa so so
you know uh i think it's important to
infuse uh you know all of our cultures
into our movies i thought it was
important to
um you know to let the cast be the best
cast that we could possibly have and not
let the idea that it should only be
white people stop us from hiring the
best people
so and i got support from the studio so
i think it's you know it's an
interesting we're living in interesting
times and movies are going to get better
and more interesting and we're going to
see stories from more different places
so
yeah amazing yeah because representation
is such an interesting conversation to
me because i've been teaching myself
filmmaking over the pandemics so
i often think about weaving sort of
indian sensibilities and there's not too
much for me to base myself off of
visually
and um also i think representation
there's kind of a personal
accountability as well like we should
all have more opportunities but where we
can't interject those moments of maybe
educating or making our cultures
respective cultures more accessible i
think that's an important initiative for
artists moving forward essential it's
essentially that
that we do it that's so we had a moment
you remember
when we did the scene it was me adria al
madrigal and tyrus gibson we're making a
scene
and nothing in scene was about us being
latinos or
you know there was no mention of it in
the scenes there was no mention of it in
in the character the description i
wasn't hired because i was latino i was
there because i was good director adios
because he was a great actor so was al
as was therese but we're different and
that was the beauty of it also so that's
amazing and we did have a moment we sort
of like all hugged and huddled up and we
were like
i can't believe this is happening and
even
you know we're all in the room but also
seeing you know
daniel that is sort of like part of the
world you know chilean and swedish and
i didn't know you grew up in west africa
yeah well now i know um
your your character to me represents
sort of like the moral compass of the
story and the film and i was curious if
in your personal life you often find
yourself being the moral compass for
others because that's a tough place to
be where you're the voice of reason and
it feels like nobody really wants to
listen to you or take you seriously
i think you should ask the people around
me
but i would i would i would say so i
think i think most of my friends and and
definitely my family
come to me for for
a lot of that i don't personally do it
in my own life but i'm great at doing it
for others
it's relatable
you know we make mistakes but it's
easier to see other people's mistakes
relatable well i want to thank both of
you for your time i look forward to
whatever you have working up in the
future and uh i'm glad i got your name
right those those youtube videos paid
off thank you so much
thank you enjoy the rest of your day hey
man how's it going
as i live and breathe matt smith how are
you i'm very well thank you is that
michael gordon in the background it is
michael jordan in the background it's a
cardboard cutout i won uh in a bet back
when they were in the finals um
so
this is your first initiation to the pop
superhero comic book culture
and i think every fan would want to know
what took so long but also what was it
about morbius that really drew you to
this role
well i was intrigued to play a villain
for one thing i've always loved we're
not meant to say this but this is the
truth i'm sorry i've always loved
vampire emojis i've always been
you know i think back of some of my
favorite movies interview with a vampire
was always obsessed with and and just
that
that idea of sort of night and day and a
villain in the dark and all that there
was a fabulous cast involved um and i i
you know i met the director daniel and
was just really taken with his approach
and what and what he wanted to do with
it and of course being in a movie of
this scale is something i hadn't done
and i thought it would be a fabulous
challenge as it turned out to be
nice now are you an avid spectator of
the culture around all these films or
was there a certain level of trepidation
because i feel like there's a lot that
comes with with the culture around these
films between discourse on the internet
there's youtube content that goes out
there's very passionate debates so it
can kind of feel overwhelming to know
you're kind of just throwing yourself in
the fire was that a concern for you
well no because i think that's part and
parcel of the culture of this type of
and luckily i've had an experience like
that with doctor who there's a similar
level of famine and and sort of um
intriguing interest
in in the world and who's playing the
parts and
everyone's entitled to their opinions so
no i think hopefully it does stir up
debate and it's like anything some
people will like it some people it just
won't be for them that's all right
yeah nice now you mentioned daniel so
i've been teaching myself filmmaking
over the course of the pandemic so
i've been really curious on what the
actor's sort of perception of a director
is like do you have particular
requirements for a director is there
certain expectations do you have or do
you have to be malleable in a sense that
it's the director's film so i'm just
gonna have to adapt myself according to
that personality because i think that's
something that often gets lost within
the artistic endeavors is you're not
only managing your own personality and
your own sort of insecurities and
experiences but you are managing that of
others as well so if you could shed some
light on that please yeah well i think i
think that's a very personal right that
was a loaded question for you
no no that's okay i think it's a very
good question i think um
yeah look i think absolutely you've got
to be malleable as an actor and you've
got to adapt and you've got to be
willing to take direction and change and
compromise but also do you expect
anything of the director yes you expect
them to be good and know more about the
story than you do and have a vision and
something you want to follow and set
tone and a way of working at least i do
and daniel certainly does that he sets a
really wonderful tone on set he's brave
he's brave with the actors he's brave
with the way he tells the story and i
think he shoots really vividly and
interestingly and i think he's got a
great eye
for filmmaking so i was i you know i
jumped at the chance to work with him to
be honest and i liked him
well i'll be patiently waiting for a
matt smith master class one day
hopefully finger fingers crossed
and i'll be patiently waiting for a
master class for you my friend hey i
appreciate that thank you for the
encouragement yeah of course mate go for
it nice meeting you enjoy the rest of
your day it's a pleasure to meet you be
lucky likewise thank you